burnley turned tori blue at the last
election for the first time in a hundred
years if leveling up means anything it
has to mean something in places like
this
i've already got them out already on
eddie liptrot opened his sweet business
just before the pandemic he voted tory
and still has faith in the prime
minister
he's doing okay
like you're saying he needs to get on
board now and get on some of these
things i'm not happy that the message is
is fuddled it's foggy it's not getting
through properly
to the working manpower i've called
myself a working man person
jim berry out shopping with his wife
glennis helped bring down the red wall
in 2019 voting tori after a lifetime
commitment to labour like many others in
this town he's only giving the prime
minister one chance
he would have to address this
that the
the poor end of the society
you know because if i think at the
moment it feels like they're being
ignored
you know so
i think he would have to address that
and he'd probably get back in then are
you seeing any evidence of levelling up
no about not not yet no
in fact at this church they say demand
for food parcels and everything else
they offer is rising
so when the prime minister talks about
promoting opportunity it needs to knock
at the door of people like jenny who
needs help finding a job and whose
aspirations are humble what sort of job
would you like to do
kitchen
i'm into like kitchen with me
obviously
i've had qualifications for it in the
past and
that's something i've always wanted to
do
everyone here has a story burnley
resident jill conway has come to the
church to support her son nathan who's
getting help for an addiction
do you think this town is struggling
what's going on for you
we should it shouldn't be like this
universal credit payments are changing
energy bills are going up and the cost
of living is rising the stakes are high
when you promise a lot to a community
like this
we don't want to see backlashes we don't
want to see crime going through the room
we don't want to see people but what
happens when people can't feed the
children
winter is coming in burnley the prime
minister's actions will have to speak
louder than his words lisa holland sky
news burnley